Jaakko and echo should you defend bad
leaders vacate your superiors to your
men think about that question this is a
good it's a good question and we haven't
done Q&A in a while that's why I want to
start off think about that should you
defend bad leaders that are people that
are in charge you should you defend them
to your men now this is really a perfect
example of the dichotomy of leadership
and this is one of those situations that
makes leadership very very hard because
it requires a nuanced balance to handle
this correctly so on one hand if we if
we say our boss is a bad leader and
doesn't know what he's doing don't
forgot the boss hey echo our boss
doesn't know what he's doing he's an
idiot we undermine his authority for
sure and we undermine the authority of
the whole chain of command yeah so
should you call out when someone sucks
you say oh that guys sucks he's terrible
should you do that to your leader the
answer is no you can't do that you can't
do that cuz you're undermining
everything so you got a horrible leader
you can't just sit there to your boys
and say hey this guy's an idiot you
can't do that however if you give full
support to this horrible boss then your
troops who know a good leader from a bad
leader they know what's stupid and what
isn't they know this they know this and
if you are sitting there back in them
100%
then they're gonna know that you either
actually agree with the bad leader which
is bad or that you're too weak to stand
up and say eh boss what we're doing is
wrong so you can't go to one extreme the
boss is an idiot you can't go to the
other extreme the boss is awesome think
about how hard that is think about what
I'm saying this is a very
challenging so what can you do well okay
first of all as a subordinate leader it
is your duty to push back right to say
hey boss I think we're doing the wrong
thing here and this is why we spend a
lot of time trying to build
relationships with our bosses so that we
can have candid conversations with them
right sometimes it's hard to do that it
is I understand
but when you have built a relationship
then you can go to your boss and say hey
look this isn't this isn't good now once
you've done that then you can go to your
go to your troops and you say hey look I
went to the boss that's what I told him
you know I told him that hey doing this
method isn't gonna work well he
explained to me while we're doing it
this is what he said so this is why
we're using this method I know it's not
popular to you guys
but it's it's here's the reason why
we're doing it so you made progress
right your guys were saying okay well he
at least stood up to the man mm-hmm and
now he gave us an answer he told us why
we're doing what we're doing so that's
good too but the other thing is one of
the easiest way to do this is to provide
an honest to Pintrest truth is gonna be
your friend here truth is gonna be your
friend now I should I just put a caveat
around that because the truth might be
you think your boss is a complete idiot
and everything he's saying is stupid
okay so I I take it back no news full-on
truth and this is so this is so
interesting too because clearly
truthfulness is a huge you know it's a
value that I've hold very dear right and
you got to be truthful and all that I'm
telling you right now do not be true if
you think your boss is an idiot and you
think the method that he's picking or
the plan he's got is stupid hmm don't be
true fool your guys and go down there
and say Boston it's not gonna help your
team right we have to be smart about
what we're doing but when you when you
do that what you need to do is keep it
somewhere in the middle okay so it when
you say something negative
don't get all crazy with the negative
don't get all nuts with the negative
what you want to do is say you say
something like hey look I'm sure there's
some better ways of doing this but this
is the decision that was made and we
need to make it work right so I'm not
saying it's horrible and say look hey
guys I'm sure there's some better ways
but guess what this is what we are being
told to do right now and we're gonna do
the best we can
notice that I'm putting it from like
them to the way I'm making it I'm taking
ownership of it this is now ours to
execute yeah so you want to do that or
you and and I also want to focus more on
as much as I can I want to focus on not
the personality of the boss but I want
to focus on like the what we're being
told type thing or what the mission is
because I don't want to bring I want to
keep the personality the boss at bay
sometimes you get a boss that has such a
raging asshole personality that you have
to say something like you just you have
to explain and that's when even then you
want to Dratch it it down a little bit
you don't say hey the boss is national
no the boss is an idiot no you don't say
that you know you say hey look guys I
know the bosses is not exactly perfect
but I think he means well with what he's
trying to do and that way we need to
focus for that reason we need to focus
on executing because not gonna help us
to sit here and complain about the boss
he might not have the greatest
personality but you know what his
intention is good
so let's support him you know what I
mean it's something like that where
you're not you're not giving him full
support but you're not completely
throwing him under the bus again this is
so hard to do because if let's face it
the boys the troops they know what's up
they know when that boss is an idiot
they know when he's unprofessional they
know when he treats you like shit they
know that stuff and so if you bow down
if you break and you give that to him
yes you're right the boss is a jerk yes
you're right the boss treats people like
shit yeah if you give them that you're
hurting the situation and that's why
also when you're in a leadership
position your job oftentimes is to
buffer between the jerk boss and the
boys you know the boys should never know
that the the kind of stupid harassment
that you get from your boss the boy
should never know that they should think
hey chocolate says this guy's good to go
we're good to go
there's never think that this guy's an
idiot hmm so again in both cases it's
like you can't go hardcore you can't go
hardcore against either the plan or the
person but you also at the same time you
need to give a little bit of a
pressure-release just a little bit of a
pressure-release you know gotta give him
just enough that they go you know what
you want them to think you want them to
think hey joko gets it he knows mm-hmm
he's not admitting it to us and good on
him he's keeping it professional they
know and they know that John Lydon they
know I don't love the boss but they know
I'm keeping a professional so therefore
they they accept what I'm saying and
they stay part of the team yeah it kind
of feels like I'm kind of imagining
myself as one of the boys you're my boss
in red we don't really like your boss
right
I feel like sure if I was made to feel
better in whatever way just a little bit
better that pressure release I said just
a little bit better about the mission
okay and I trust you because of how you
always handle things or whatever you
know what all right it's not the best
funnest whatever it's not my first
choice but at least we're doing it
together you know I trust you and all
right let's do this kind of thing and
one of the key things you just said is
trust so if you trust me and the boss is
saying to do something completely
ridiculous and I come down and say echo
guess what we're gonna do we're gonna
we're gonna dig this hole and then we're
gonna fill it back in I want to do it
six times today let's get to work and
you know it's stupid yeah and I come
down and try and sell that to you yeah
without any explanation with that voice
yeah with that voice I'm gonna lose
trust you're gonna you're not gonna
trust me as much now if I come down and
say hey hey boys hey bring it this is
what's going on yeah see I'm going back
to you
going back to the leadership listen hey
guys here's what's going on I know this
is gonna come across as a strange to ask
we're gonna get it done we got to dig
these holes I don't want to fill them
back in and we're actually gonna do this
six times today again I know it's not
exactly what we were planning to do
today but look let's get after it let's
get it done and let's prove to everybody
that we can make this happen faster than
and all Sun were we're energy working
together yeah you know it's no factor
whereas again if I go into like a dorky
nerd voice and try and say we are going
to do this because it's the best plan
ever yeah you I'm losing trust with you
yeah I'm actually hurting my trust so
this is a really really nuanced thing
and my best advice here is to try and
keep it in the middle right it's real
and I'll tell you probably lean a little
bit lean towards being professional lean
towards supporting the chain of command
because because the guys are gonna know
when you give them that little little
pressure relief you say hey I know this
is code this is a little bit of a
strange plan as soon as I say that I was
like okay here
yes working that know we'll do whatever
he says hey Jocko okay Jonica we get it
you got it you got you got to have us do
this cool let's do it yeah it's when I
come down and say and again you'll
realize that this is this is the
opposite I say all the time you know if
you come down and say the bosses plan we
got to do this I always saw that as like
the worst possible leadership is hey we
got to do this because we were told to
do it that's the worst possible
leadership not saying to do that what
I'm saying is a little pressure relief
just a little pressure relief of hey
look I threw up a different plan I
thought my plan was a little bit better
boss came up with this this idea we're
gonna go for it it's close enough just
something like that just like hey I know
I know yeah that's it little a little a
little nugget yeah I feel like I would
feel if you were to be like this is such
a dumb plan and I don't know why we got
to do it or whatever I'd be like wait
wait then why are we DL is that you know
you're Zack you're my bot like why we're
doing it then you know and I wouldn't
want to do that
no see yeah that's like right in the
middle there it's leaning towards being
professional it's leaning towards
supporting the chain of command
yeah with just enough of a pressure
relief to have
a story it's cool this is real real
quick this was in do take your time I
don't want you tell me the longest story
we're going back to the ninth grade and
this is reading high school college it's
weird that I even thought of this so we
you know how like in in class right this
high early high school freshman you know
in class you they're like hey get into
groups we're gonna do this thing and so
we got into these groups and we did some
project little thing during class we're
done halfway through class we're done
and we're about to present the teacher
looks at it and it was like oh you guys
got to do it again but the teacher
doesn't tell everyone she tells just
this one girl Marla is there named Marla
yeah so Marla comes back from talking to
teacher and she's like she was kind of a
leader no one desi but she at that point
she was kind of a little leader than
liaison between the guru and the teacher
so she comes back she's like like we got
to do it again and we're and everyone's
like what yes we got to do it again like
you could tell she had accepted it but
just her being like sighing kind of
demonstrated that a she feels the pain -
I dig it but hey guys you know we're not
gonna complain right it was just that
little subtle thing but that's exactly
what it did it kind of it basically
accepted the order that none of us
really wanted to hear but at the same
time she demonstrated that a she feels
it too you know and that's what we did
again of course and whatever I don't
even know what great we got an a-plus
I'm sure Marla working her leadership
skills on yeah it was weird that I mean
I don't know necessarily that she
intended to do that but that was the
exact effect and you can thinking back I
can see the the elements you know the
little pressure release was her not
saying don't talk to me like that she
said we gotta do to get you know she
didn't lose anybody her just her little
she how mannerisms you know what she
didn't do she didn't jump completely on
board with the teacher yeah and be like
we got to do this again it sucked no
times like hey look we got we have to do
this again ya know what I mean she just
the tone it's permeated enough and I'll
tell you this this question I'm
surprised it took so long to get this
question because this is a really really
good question and it also is a
incredibly important skill to be able to
walk this line and it's tricky to do
and it's a very it's it's sort of this
might be one of the this is like the
type of thing that helped me a lot in
when I was in the teams was just being
able to do this enough cuz you have to
do some dumb shit the teams man and you
know what it's like okay being able to
translate a stupid something stupid and
give enough pressure relief to to make
guys not just go jock was just you know
company guy yeah right it's a company
guy look he just so he doesn't stand up
for us no actually I do but this is you
know like lifestyle telling that story
about doing paperwork
well I'm like no we're gonna do all the
paperwork III went I held the company
line but like in such a dynamic or such
an overboard way that guys are like okay
yeah we're gonna win yeah this is a
competition
yeah so that's good times yeah it's like
a meat because it seems like okay all
that paperwork it's it's almost like the
paperwork was like enough front dues
like a what right the odds against them
kind of right where who told us to do
the paperwork and you were like yeah
it's awesome yeah that's something I've
done I've actually done that a fair
amount I talked about the story before
but like an Officer Candidate School
every little stupid rule that they threw
at us I did it to the end three and had
everybody that lasted and agree where
they were just going yeah in yeah going
ballistic
so a story like that where we're just
going we're gonna take with or take the
order and carry it out to the extremes
and take pride in doing that was a
little tactic better just by me along
the way yeah yeah we're gonna do that
we're gonna do it so hard you're not
even know what your name was that's
another tactic you can take for sure
they want us to polish these boots they
want to something wants to clean this
thing we'll do it watch this